dans une classe comme celle-ci
avec plus de 150 enfants
et pendant six ans.
Il m'arrivait de venir à l'école
et d'apprendre que l'un de mes camarades était mort.
Aujourd'hui, presque rien n'a changé.
Il n'y a toujours pas d'électricité dans mon village.
Les gens meurent encore au Burkina Faso,
et l'accès à l'eau potable
est encore un grand problème.
J'ai eu de la chance, parce cela fait partie de la vie
quand on grandit dans un endroit comme celui-là.
Mais j'ai eu de la chance.
J'ai eu une bourse.
Je suis allé faire des études en Allemagne.
Alors, je suppose
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire que j'explique que c'est un immense privilège
pour moi de me trouver devant vous aujourd'hui.
Partir de Gando, mon village au Burkina Faso
et arriver à Berlin en Allemagne et devenir architecte,
est un grand, très grand pas en avant.
Mais que faire de ce privilège ?
Depuis mes années d'étudiant, je voulais offrir
de meilleures opportunités pour les autres enfants de Gando.
Je voulais utiliser mes connaissances pour construire une école.
Mais comment faire quand on est étudiant
et qu'on n'a pas d'argent ?
Bien sûr, je faisais des dessins
et je me faisais payer.
Mais récolter des fonds n'était pas facile.
J'ai même demandé à mes camarades étudiants
de dépenser moins d'argent en cafés et en cigarettes
pour financer mon projet d'école.
À ma grande surprise, en deux ans
j'ai pu recueillir 50 000 dollars.
Quand je suis retourné à Gando
pour leur annoncer la bonne nouvelle
les gens étaient aux anges,
mais quand ils ont vu
que je comptais construire en argile
ils ont été choqués.
« Une construction en argile ne résiste pas à la saison des pluies
et Francis veut construire une école en argile.
C'est pour ça qu'il a passé tout ce temps
en Europe, pour faire des études
au lieu de travailler dans les champs avec nous ? »
Chez moi, on construit tout le temps en argile
mais ils ne voient aucune différence par rapport à la boue.
J'ai du convaincre tout le monde.
J'ai commencé à parler avec la communauté
et je suis arrivé à convaincre tout le monde
et nous avons pu commencer à travailler.
Les femmes, les hommes,
tous dans le village
ont participé de ce processus de construction.
On m'a permis d'utiliser des techniques traditionnelles
comme les sols en argile, par exemple.
les hommes se mettent comme ça, en battant
pendant des heures
puis viennent leur mères
et elles se mettent à battre en cette position
pendant des heures, elles mouillent et battent en même temps
Puis c'est le tour des polisseurs.
Ils polissent avec une pierre pendant des heures.
Voici le résultat,
très doux, comme les fesses d'un bébé
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas du photoshop. (Rires)
Voici l'école, construite avec la communauté.
Les murs sont faits entièrement
de blocs d'argile comprimés de Gando.
La structure du toit
est en barres d'acier bon marché
qui sont normalement cachées par le ciment.
Dans les salles de classe, le plafond est fait
de ces deux éléments ensemble.
Dans cette école, il y avait une idée très simple à la base
pour qu'une salle de classe soit confortable.
N'oublions pas qu'il peut faire 45 degrés au Burkina Faso,
et donc par un simple système de ventilation
je voulais que la salle de classe
soit adaptée à l'enseignement et l'apprentissage.
Voici le projet aujourd'hui,
12 ans plus tard, il est encore dans d'excellentes conditions.
Et les enfants, ils l'adorent.
Et pour moi et ma communauté,
ce projet a eu un immense succès.
Il a ouvert de nouvelles possibilités
de réaliser d'autres projets à Gando.
J'ai donc pu réaliser beaucoup de projets
et je vais vous parler ici
de trois d'entre eux.
Le premier, bien sûr, est l'agrandissement de l'école.
Comment expliquer les plans et les questions d'ingénierie
à des gens qui ne savent ni lire ni écrire ?
J'ai d'abord construit un prototype comme celui-ci.
L'innovation consistait à construire une voûte en argile.
Donc, j'ai sauté dessus comme ça,
avec mon équipe, et ça marche.
La communauté regardait, et ça marchait.
Donc, on a pu construire. (Rires)
Et on a continué à construire, et voici le résultat.
Les enfants sont heureux, et ils adorent.
La communauté est très fière, nous l'avons fait.
Et même les animaux, comme cet âne,
aiment nos bâtiments.
(Rires)
Le projet suivant est la bibliothèque de Gando.
Et vous voyez, nous avons essayé d'introduire
des idées différentes dans nos bâtiments,
Mais souvent, nous n'avons pas beaucoup de matériel.
Une chose que nous avons à Gando : les pots en argile.
Nous voulions les utiliser pour créer des ouvertures.
Nous les transportons, comme vous le voyez,
vers le site de construction.
Nous commençons à les couper,
puis nous les mettons sur le toit
avant de couler le béton ,
et vous obtenez ça.
Les ouvertures permettent à l'air chaud de s'échapper
et laissent entrer la lumière .
Très simple.
Mon projet le plus récent à Gando
est celui d'une école secondaire.
Permettez- moi de le partager avec vous.
L'innovation dans ce projet
est de modéliser la boue comme vous le faites avec le béton.
Comment modélisez-vous la boue ?
Nous commençons à créer de nombreux mortiers, comme vous pouvez le voir,
et quand tout est prêt,
lorsque nous trouvons la meilleure recette
et le meilleur ajustement,
nous commençons à travailler en communauté.
Et des fois je peux même m'en aller.
Ils s'en chargent eux-mêmes.
Je suis là pour vous parler de cette manière.
Un autre facteur à Gando est la pluie.
Lorsqu'il pleut,
nous nous empêchons de couvrir nos murs fragiles
contre la pluie.
Ne le confondez pas avec Christo et Jeanne -Claude.
C'est notre façon de protéger nos murs.
(Rires).
La pluie au Burkina Faso vient très vite,
et ensuite, il y a des inondations
partout dans le pays.
Mais pour nous, la pluie est une bonne chose
elle apporte le sable et le gravier de la rivière
que nous utilisons pour construire.
Nous attendons que la pluie cesse.
Nous prenons le sable, nous le mélangeons avec l'argile,
et nous poursuivons la construction.
C'est tout.
Le projet de Gando a toujours été axé sur la formation des gens,
parce que je voulais que si un jour
je venais à mourir,
au moins une personne de Gando
puisse poursuivre ce travail.
Mais je vais vous surprendre. Je suis toujours en vie.
(Rires)
Mes compatriotes peuvent utiliser leurs compétences
pour gagner de l'argent.
Généralement, pour gagner de l'argent, un jeune de Gando
doit quitter le village
aller en ville, et même parfois quitter le pays
et certains ne sont jamais revenus,
affaiblissant ainsi la communauté.
Mais maintenant, ils peuvent rester dans le village,
travailler sur différents sites
et gagner de l'argent pour nourrir leurs familles.
Il y a une nouvelle qualité dans ce travail .
Vous le savez.
J'ai reçu de nombreuses récompenses pour ce travail.
Bien sûr, cela nous a ouvert des opportunités.
Je suis devenu, moi-même célèbre.
Mais la raison pour laquelle je fais ce que je fais
c'est ma communauté.
Quand j'étais un enfant
je partais étudier
et je revenais à Gando durant les vacances.
Et à chaque fin de période de vacances,
je devais dire au revoir à ma communauté
en allant de porte en porte.
Toutes les femmes à Gando ouvraient ainsi leurs vêtements
et me donnaient leur dernier sou .
Dans ma culture, c'est un symbole de grande affection.
Comme tout enfant de sept ans, j'étais impressionné.
Un jour, j'ai posé la question à ma mère,
« Pourquoi ces femme m'aiment-elles tant ? »
(Rires)
Elle répondit :
« Elles contribuent aux frais de ton éducation
en espérant qu'un jour tu réussiras
et tu reviendras pour aider
à améliorer la qualité de vie de la communauté ».
J'espère avoir fait la fierté de ma communauté
à travers ce travail,
et j’espère avoir été en mesure de vous démontrer la force
de la communauté,
et d'avoir montré que l'architecture
peut être une source d'inspiration pour les communautés
afin qu'elles façonnent leur avenir.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci. Merci. Merci
Merci. Merci. (Applaudissements)